this is you your young hopeful curious
and you've gathered the resources to
create a love potion to attract your
crush using now today the overall
consensus on witchcraft is that it's
motherfucking bitching choose which
black or white magic good or evil you
must determine your own path I've always
wanted to be black but 400 years ago
oh hey marry me I told you I'm already
married what the fuck and it's kinda
made me wonder like if there are such
things as witches
then we'll some of us just be naturally
better at it than others
yo yo yo a dog you want to check out my
new spell come on just listen fine
yo which crap that's this shit I do like
Oh spells and shit magic baby fo life oh
okay bitch okay I get it
okay you're cooler than I am because
you're a black magic freestyle spell
casting wizard I get it okay I wish I
was you but I'm not I'm white magic man
she's a black candle stay off and Gotham
[Music]